les élections présidentielle et
législatives arrivent à grands pas si
vous êtes dans l'incapacité de vous
rendre dans votre bureau de vote mais
que vous souhaitez aller voter vous
pouvez faire une procuration
elle permet de mandater quelqu'un pour
aller voter à votre place alors
concrètement comment ça marche et bien
une procuration s'effectue en deux
étapes étape une il vous faut remplir
vos informations et celle de votre
mandataire deux choix s'offrent alors à
vous vous pouvez soit faire une demande
en ligne via la plateforme ma
procuration point gouv.fr soit remplir
un formulaire papier il est disponible
sur le site de l'administration
française services ti république est
point fr la procédure peut être la
procédure de démarches en ligne
peut-être simplifie énormément les
choses il faut a disposé effectivement
certaines informations mais qui vous
sont demandées sur la démarche en ligne
et ça simplifie à ce moment là quand on
passe sur le site ça simplifie
énormément là la procédure de validation
ce que j'insiste naissent les deux
choses là d'abord la démarche est
ensuite la validation par l'officier de
police judiciaire
[Musique]
ce qui nous amène à notre deuxième étape
pour faire valider votre identité et
donc votre demande il faut vous rendre
dans l'un de ces deux lieux donc une
brigade de gendarmerie ou un
commissariat
vous devez être munis d'un justificatif
d'identité et selon votre choix
précédents soin de votre formulaire
papier elle soit du numéro de référence
que vous avez obtenus lors de votre
demande en ligne
qu'est ce qui change cette année par
rapport aux années précédentes
eh bien depuis le 1er janvier 2022 vous
pouvez choisir de donner votre voix un
électeur extérieur à votre commune par
contre la personne en question devra
bien entendu se déplacer dans le bureau
de vote où vous êtes inscrits pour faire
exprimer votre voix une procuration peut
s'effectuer à n'importe quel moment
attention cependant aux délais de
traitement de votre demande et à
l'acheminement jusqu'à votre commune
évitez de vous y prendre à la dernière
minute on écoute pourquoi se mobilise
beaucoup de gens
de façon
intense dans les deux semaines qui
précèdent l'élection vous avez
possibilité de faire une procuration
pour une élection en particulier elle
serait alors à préciser lors de votre
démarche vous pouvez également faire une
procuration pour une durée déterminée
jusqu'à un an au maximum si vous êtes
inscrit sur une liste électorale
communale à noter si vous êtes
finalement dans la capacité d'aller
voter le jour j pas besoin de résilier
votre procuration il s'est fait
simplement d'informer votre mandataire
vous pourrez alors allés voter
personnellement dans votre bureau de
vote il celui ci n'est pas venu bien
évidemment voté à votre place avant vous
prochaine échéance pour les élections
les 10 et 24 avril pour les
présidentielles et les 12 et 19 juin
pour les législatives